what's up ketchup crew welcome to the
weekly ketchup on YouTube where we bring
you the biggest news of the week in
movies and TV and this week it is the
golden tomato Awards with the best
reviewed movies and TV shows of 2019
enjoy it's time for the 21st annual
golden tomato Awards here's your host
ness Perez what's going on ketchup crew
it is official the golden tomato awards
have been announced and it has nothing
to do with produce and everything to do
with the best reviews movie shows and
actors so let's take a look at some of
the big movie winners right now in the
ketchup and find out who the golden
tomato goes to so Ryan tomatoes gives
out golden tomato awards to the best
reviewed movies of 2019 according to
adjusted tomato meters but we also have
golden tomato fan categories that are
based on fan votes and guess what you
still have time to vote a Tron tomatoes
calm so don't leave just yet wait until
the end of this video and then go vote
okay so first up is the golden tomato
Award winner for best movie wide-release
and that tomato goes to the certified
fresh' avengers end game the critics
consensus is the end game was exciting
entertaining and emotionally impactful
not to mention it delivered a satisfying
finale to Marvel's epic infinity saga
and forced us to hold our P for three
hours in the theater plus it got us even
more excited for what's to come in the
next phase of Marvel movies so let's
take a moment to thank our man for his
service whatever it takes okay next up
is our best movie limited release
category and that golden tomato award
goes to I feel like I should be opening
some type of envelope for this parasite
and it's actually no surprise because
the Golden Globe winner for Best Foreign
Language Film is dominating our awards
leaderboard which tracks how many awards
a movie gets all award season with 73
wins already well make that 74 with the
golden tomato although it kind of feels
like maybe you should have given the
movie of Peach anyway lucky for us we
got an acceptance speech straight from
the cast of parasite on the Golden
Globes orange carpet check it out I want
to thank you like actors and selectable
thank you so much yeah
it's hard to properly describe this
social political satire but the Chicago
sun-times Richard Roeper came close when
he said this is a film of dramatic power
innovative comedy romantic poetry and
melancholy Beauty jeez Roper I was just
gonna say it's really good yeah our next
golden tomato award goes to the best
reviewed action-adventure movie of 2019
and that's John wig chapter three
Parabellum it was praised by critics for
its hard-hitting brilliantly
choreographed over-the-top action plus
you know Keanu Reeves I mean if only
Keanu knew how much we talked about him
on the ketchup please tag him in this oh
wait don't he doesn't use social media
because he's cooler than us I forgot
what and the third installment in this
particular Kayano Ruiz franchise from
which there are many successful ones to
choose perform the even better than the
previous two films and set the stage for
a fourth John wick coming out on Keano
Day May 21st 2021 the same day that the
matrix for also comes out should we make
shirts next up we're handing out the
golden tomato award for the best
reviewed comedy movie to book-smart
the hilarious coming-of-age story that
starts caitlyn beaver and beanie
Feldstein Deever bless us with her
presence on the Golden Globes dirt
carpet where we captured her reaction to
winning the golden tomato me the chills
such an honor thank you so much critics
you're the best Jesus we feel your
excitement Caitlyn much like Roger Ebert
calm film critic Monica Castillo she
feels that book smart is incredibly fun
to watch again and again and let me
throw in one more again for good measure
again that was - moving on Mase listen
it is very important that you keep the
safe and finally in the category of best
reviewed horror movie the golden tomato
award is going to the mega horror hit us
critics say the director Jordan fields
beat the sophomore jinx after 2017 to
get out with a second inventive and
ambitious horror film this one also
landed at the top of our best horror
movies of the decade list so check that
episode out if you haven't already and
there's just no denying just how horror
epic this movie is with great dual
performances not just from Lupita
Nyong'o but also over supporting casts
like wince
Dook Elizabeth moss and the kids
Shahadah right Joseph and Evan Alex
so freaking people so there you have it
friends let us know what you think of
these winners in the comment section and
for the full list of golden tomato Award
winners and to vote in the fan
categories please vote head on over to
Ron Tomatoes calm and now back to the
21st annual golden tomato Awards here's
your host Brett thanks Kyle
what's up ketchup crew welcome back to
the golden tomato Awards today we're
handing out GTA's to some of the best
reviewed TV shows of 2019 right now on
the ketchup as a reminder Ron tomatoes
gives out golden tomato awards to the
best reviewed movies and TV shows of
each year according to adjusted tomato
meter but we also have golden tomato fan
categories that are based on fan votes
and guess what you still have time to
vote at Ron Tomatoes calm so just be the
change you wish to see in the world man
of entertainment so kicking things off
is the best reviewed new TV show of the
year and that's HBO's Watchmen which
also picked up the golden tomato for the
best reviewed superhero show as well two
words Regina King Congrats
oh yeah that's three words
the critics consensus for Watchmen which
is based on the hit graphic novel from
the 80s is that it expertly builds on
its source material to create an
impressive identity of its own and with
great performances from stars like
Regina king and Jeremy Irons a crazy
cliffhanger for season 1 and blue
penises fans and critics are definitely
wanting more for the best reviewed
returning TV show of 2019 and this also
happens to be the best reviewed comedy
the golden tomato award goes to fleabags
season 2 and this was also our highest
reviewed season of the decade check out
that episode if you haven't already and
it has a trophy case filled with Emmys
and Golden Globes for the show and its
star and creator Phoebe Waller Bridge so
if that was all really confusing just
know that this show is one Matt awards
and you need to start watching it right
now
Roger Ebert hums Alison shoemaker wisely
called the second season pretty much
perfect and somehow better than the
first season and here to accept the
golden tomato award and by here I mean
on the Golden Globes red carpet is one
of the show stars that we just love to
hate Brett Gelman I'm very grateful it's
amazing yeah it's amazing that's
something that I care so much about
people also care about another show
that's had a dominant award season HBO's
Chernobyl can now add a golden tomato
Award to the list because it was the
best reviewed miniseries or limited
series of 2019 the critics consensus is
that Chernobyl dramatizes the 1986
nuclear accident one of the worst
human-made catastrophes in history with
sterling craft and an intelligent
dissection of Institutional rot and at
the Golden Globes Chernobyl star Jared
Harris had a message for the critics
after learning about the show's gold and
tomato wonderful taste they're not wrong
once again wrong Tomatoes that's it
right Jared Harris says it it's got to
be true and for the best reviewed sci-fi
or fantasy TV show of 2019 the GTA goes
to Netflix is dark this German time
traveller series is often compared to
the hit duffer brother show stranger
things but new york times TV critic
lawrence where said that in dark second
season its ambitions are closer to the
wire either way that's some seriously
good company to be compared to
and finally the golden tomato award for
best reviewed horror TV show of the year
goes to the first season of evil this
CBS show is about a female clinical
psychologist a priest in training and a
blue-collar contractor who all walk into
a bar I'm just kidding they all join up
to investigate extraordinary occurrences
evil is a hit with critics who say it is
smartly written and effectively
unsettling and works best when it dares
to delve into the depths of the
uncomfortable questions that it poses
plus it stars Luke Cage and that's just
a win for all of us oh my god I know so
there you have it friends let us know
what you think of these winners in the
comments section and for the full list
of golden tomato Award winners and to
vote in the fan categories please do
that it's so fun head on over to Ron
Tomatoes calm alright friends thanks for
tuning into the weekly ketchup on
YouTube we love seeing your face make
sure to tap that subscribe button and
notification bell so you don't miss any
future episodes at the ketchup as always
I'm no surprise and we'll see you guys
in the next video
[Music]
[Music]